welcome to this meeting of the council i
will now ask reverend
nick rowan to lead us in prayers thank
you
start with a verse from isaiah 2.
in the last days many people will come
and say come let us go to the mountain
of the lord to the temples of the god of
jacob who will teach us
his ways
the law will go out from zion the word
of lord from jerusalem
he will judge between the nations and
settle disputes for peoples
they will beat their swords into
plowshares
and their spears into pruning hooks
nation will not take up sword against
nation
nor will they train for war anymore
father god we thank you for this picture
of promised future peace for all the
world
between all peoples
we pray for peace today between ukraine
and russia
bless the work of peacemakers diplomats
change the hearts of anyone minded to
violence and aggression
we also pray for peace healing and
restoration for the residents of this
district
as we emerge from restrictions due to
coronavirus
and almighty god from whom comes every
good and perfect gift
we pray that this meeting will be
conducted in a spirit of justice and
truth
wisdom and charity
we pray that mindful of their
responsibility and the needs of those
they serve
each councillor and officer will use
their influence in this meeting
to promote the building up of community
and neighborhood
help them to seek the way of love and
peace
through whom him who is the prince of
peace our savior jesus christ
amen
thank you uh reverend cannon nick rowan
um
i know that you're a very busy man thank
you for coming and you'll take your
depart now thank you
please be seated
[Music]
members when i invite you to speak
please wait until there is a microphone
in front of you before speaking as
microphones are needed for the hearing
loop and for the audio recording
please use the antibacterial wipes if
you do touch the microphones
members
voting will be done on a show of hands
in line with the constitution
i will ask for a show of hands four
then against
recommendations and then for abstaining
given the size of this room and the
numbers of us present please can i ask
that you put your hands up clearly high
in the air so that it can be easily seen
by all and leave it up until i ask you
to lower it
the normal rules of debate apply
no member should speak for longer than
five minutes
and can i please ask
you not to repeat anything previously
said
all those indicating to speak will be
given an opportunity to speak once
agenda item one
apologies for absence
we have received from councillors
constable and councillors td knight
mrs jones lumley june lumley
j e newport l j newport c m stanley
councillor western
are there any more apologies
councillor wilkinson
thank you councillor wilkinson council
agenda item two
minutes of the meeting held on the 2nd
of november
7th of november
and the extraordinary meeting held on
the 25th of january 2022 councillor
wooden point of information please madam
chairman go ahead
thank you um
members if um
you could turn to page nine of the uh
minutes um you will see towards the
bottom of the page
a question that was asked by councillor
hoy who asked a supplementary question
around the classification
as a theater and why the mill arts and
event center was reclassified from d2 to
f2 following the abolition of d2 as a
result of changes in planning
classifications in 2020
the leader advised that an appropriate
answer would be provided outside the
meeting
which would also be shared on the
website and with all members
uh councillor hoy my apologies um your i
don't think you were surprised on the
night to know that i hadn't got an
answer off the cuff on such a technical
question
but i do apologize
there was an oversight
and i think it's right and proper that
tonight with your permission madam
chairman i'll read that answer out and i
will make sure that you re receive a
written response counselor
and it is also published on the website
in 2020 the government revised the use
of classes order which categorized the
use of buildings and land for planning
purposes
this involved abolishing some of the
existing use classes and creating a
series of new use classes
as part of this process the former use
class d2 places for assembly and leisure
was abolished and its previous contents
distributed amongst the new
use classes e f1 and f2
as part of this process the relevant
statutory instrument set out that halls
primarily for the use of the community
would now sit within the new use class
f2
local community uses thank you madam
chairman
thank you councillor wooten
for raising that point of information
we will now go back to the agenda item
two minutes of the meeting members are
you happy for me to sign the minutes of
the meeting held on the 2nd of november
7th of december end of the extraordinary
meeting held on the 25th of january
is that agreed members
great
thank you
agenda item 3
declarations of interest
uh interest in item 6.1
uh as a member of barling magna parish
council
thank you chairman item seven
by virtue of being a member of raleigh
town council thank you thank you
council award
yes madam chairman it's um
item seven in regards to the john fisher
open space item the asset transfer thank
you thank you madam reward
councillor sparring
likewise gemma being a member of raley
town council
thank you councillor sparring
councillor
thank you madam chairman a non-pecuniary
interest and item seven of being a
member for raleigh town council thank
you
thank you chairman uh non-pecuniary item
number six by virtue my partner is our a
barling parish councillor thank you
chairman councilman
council
uh myers chairman also uh item number
six in the fact that my wife is a member
of the barley magnum parish council
thank you councilman
interest
madam chairman item seven same with
razertown council
thank you
and council emil
uh yes item seven has been a member of
raley town council thank you thank you
councilman
have i missed anybody out at all
okay thank you for that moving on to
agenda item four
reports from the executive and
committees to council
members there are none
agenda item five
local council tax support scheme
councillor smith the portfolio holder
finance services will introduce the
report
thank you chairman
the council has got a statutory
obligation to have a council tax support
scheme in place for each financial year
the same scheme has been in place for
many years it's an old scheme it's
cumbersome it's bureaucratic
and it's time for its review
the review is presented to you within
the report and the appendix
if i can just go over
one or two
key elements
it's a new banded scheme it's proposed
to be introduced for
22-23 with the following objectives
to simplify the scheme for residents to
understand so that they understand what
they're entitled to either 0 25 50 or 75
percent of their council tax bill based
on their eligible income
to simplify the application process for
the local council tech support scheme
making it a quick online application to
replace a 28-page
written form
to ensure that residents receive the
local council tax support that they're
entitled to more quickly and reduce the
number of changes they are likely to
undergo meaning they're more likely to
have financial certainty and less likely
to end up in arrears
to target support to those most in need
with the maximum support increased to 75
percent of the bill compared to 72
percent currently
and to improve the efficiency of the
council's revenues and benefits team to
release capacity for value-added work
such as income maximization support to
residents and to provide value for money
to the wider public purse
the
recommendation is printed on page 9.2
in two parts
however
this scheme this new scheme has taken
some time
to put together and during that time
the impact of covid has been much longer
running than most than all of us i think
would have wanted
the schemes taken some time to work up
and
changes have happened
perhaps most importantly
we've seen inflationary pressures
develop and certainly there are some
headline figures around fuel inflation
with that in mind
i would like to make the following
amendment
which i think as if by magic will appear
on the screen in front of us
and if anyone's not able to see that we
have got some
printed copies
i'll start reading i'm sure it'll appear
in a moment
that the council introduces a transition
scheme for 22 23 to ensure that no
resident is adversely financially
impacted during twenty two twenty three
this additional support would be applied
automatically to bills
without residents needing to apply
and the revenues and benefits team will
provide ongoing tailored advice and
support to those affected to ensure that
they are in receipt of all the income
they are entitled to
the cost to rdc is estimated to be
around 36 k which could be met from
general under spends during this year
the sure being 21 22.
so just as a recap madam chairman
this is a good scheme
but we've recognized the challenge of
this moment in time
and i'm happy to move the
uh the recommendation on 9.1 in its two
parts with the amendment as shown on the
screen thank you
thank you councillor smith do you have a
seconder for this council of woodson
thank you
councillor mrs mason
thank you
madam chairman
understand that the consultation
response was 31 out of 86 000 residents
which is
statistically irrelevant
the level of council tax benefit support
was reduced for working age claimants
when the local council tax support
scheme replaced the council tax benefit
in 2013.
the proposal to implement a simple
banded scheme is welcomed
both for the ease of application and the
cost and time savings to rochefort
district council
this new scheme will affect working age
claimants only roughly half of the
claimants and most would
appear to receive a minor increase which
again is welcomed
[Music]
i was concerned
about the hardship fund which adds to
the very administrative complexity that
rdc is attempting to resolve and would
not necessarily help all that are
affected however the portfolio holder's
amendment
to protect the residents adversely
affected and there was 232 residents who
were going to lose out by an average of
seven pounds 25 a week
and this is in a case a time
where we have raising
energy bills high field costs increasing
mortgage rates a tax hike planned in
april by the government and rising food
costs so the amendment is both welcome
and acceptable
and i in the present circumstances i
will support
this amendment thank you
thank you councillor mason
council ahoy
thank you uh chairman
again i came to this meeting with a
different view i i first want to
thank councillor smith
for removing the
minimum income floor for self-employed
people
or whoever did that is very welcome
because it saved me doing my normal
motion to this item i'm very very
pleased with that also i have here
a draft amendment i was going to put
forward but again councillor smith's
amendment does very much what i had
written down here not quite as much but
certainly it's enough for me to vote for
this amendment and for the
for the policy as a whole so thank you
very much smith i welcome your
the um amendment thank you council ahoy
councillor mcpherson
thank you um i'll just keep this uh
brief chairman
this is good news to hear when there's a
united
caring rocha district council looking
after our residents the 232 who would
have been seven pound 25 worse off
we are looking after them from your
conservative district council thank you
chairman thank you councilman mcpherson
it doesn't appear to be any more
members that wish to speak
there are the two recommendations set
out on pages 5.5 5.6 of the report at
paragraph 9.1
that the proposed changes to the lcts
scheme be approved to come into effect
from the 1st of april
2022 as detailed in the section 13a
policy appendix 1.
second
is that the updated discretionary
reduction in council tax liability
policy be approved to come into effect
from the 1st of april 2022
as detailed in the section 13 a 1 c
policy
councilor wilkinson
thank you chair i may well be telling
you um or advising the same as the
monitor is about to say do we not need
to vote on the amendment first as well
that's what i was going to say thank you
thank you
so item three is that the council
introduced a transition scheme for the
2022-23
to ensure no resident is adversely
financially impacted during 22-23
this additional support will be applied
automatically to bills without residents
needing to apply
and the revenues and benefits team will
provide ongoing tailored advice and
support to those affected to ensure they
are in receipt of all income they are
entitled to
the cost to rdc is estimated to be
a circuit 36 000
which could be 36 000 k which could be
met from general underspends this year
members those in favor
for the amendment
thank you please lower your hands that
is unanimous thank you
so
having read one two and three out um
if what if you're all in agreement we'll
take these on block
those in favor
thank you members that is unanimous and
carried
item six
assets transfer little wakering open
space
councillor sparring portfolio holder for
environment and place will introduce the
report
thank you chairman
if i may members the presentation that
i'm about to give in relation to item
number six will also apply effectively
to item number seven there are two
transfers of assets
i think as you've already seen this
evening there's a number of us involved
with both barling and ready town council
and it doesn't stop there i think most
of the councillors here have some
involvement with the local parishes
i think we're all fully aware that most
of the parishes would like to take more
responsibility and be able to give some
tlc to their local area
one of the cheap areas they can do this
is in the recreational area
and
both these parishes have expressed the
wish to take responsibility for the
recreational areas in their
area along with other town other
parishes that will be coming down the
road with this request and some that
have already done it in the past
while this process seems to have taken
far longer than in my view it should
have done
and we know that not all the eyes have
been dotted and the t's been crossed
the feeling from all parties is that
they want this to go through
everybody has worked very hard to
progress these items heads of terms have
been agreed
and the recommendation
chairman that is in relating to item six
and number seven leaves the final
parts to mr hutton and myself to work
with the various town parish councils i
foresee no reason why these proposals
shouldn't go through and that we come to
a satisfactory conclusion for all
parties involved thank you chairman
thank you councillor sparring do you
have a second for that
counselor myers
thank you madam chairman uh i was so i
would like to second that but first i
was just heard from barling magna parish
council a vote of thanks to dave sparing
and marcus hotten for all the work that
they've been putting in for some
considerable time to get this to where
it is at the moment um i think they both
deserve a bit of congratulations
especially with the amount of work
that's been going on in the background
this time of year
um there was one thing in the appendix
that's uh apparently they were people
weren't allowed into the park apart from
eight to six monday to friday but i
understand that is going to be rectified
and changed
and i've thoroughly second this
german thank you councillor myers
do we have anyone who wishes to speak
councillor mrs mason
thank you i'm pleased that uh
barling parish council are getting the
result they wanted on this
um
just a couple of points i i was a little
bit confused that the two heads of turns
were slightly different which i would
have thought bearing in mind there's two
applications they would have been
relatively simple
and the same but i would like just to
ask the i assume it's the
monitoring officer or whoever's involved
in this
a couple of questions ahead of terms on
this one the parry
term it says with the option of renewal
i mean any contract when it comes to its
end can ultimate normally be renewed if
the parties
agreed to that i'm a little bit
concerned that this might this comment
might
[Music]
cause a commitment to rdc in the future
albeit in 125 years time and i wonder if
the legal officer could just reassure me
that that doesn't commit the council for
125 years to do another 125 years so i'm
sure that's not the intention
the
um other point that
i am slightly concerned at
is that
it says we're going to
they're going to maintain the demise and
that's obvious and i'm sure they'll keep
it in very good repair however i would
like to see included in the maintenance
and repairs
comments i would like to see an
inspection schedule put in even if it's
only once every five years i think we
have a duty
to
look after our asset even if we've
leased it out
and
i haven't seen and i don't know if this
is necessary and again i refer to the
legal officer for this there's no remedy
for breach in there
which obviously would apply to the
inspection schedule and
i um also picked up the point that
council misses avery but that i think we
ought to take out the eight to six pm
monday to friday i think it rather
defeats the objective okay thank you
thank you councillor mason
thank you chairman
in response to council mrs mason's um
questions with regards to the option of
renewal i'm sure uh mr horton will take
that note of that and
it will be part of his discussions with
the parish council with regards to the
inspection schedule um
that can be written into the lease
with regards to no remedy for the breach
this is purely a heads of terms the
detailed lease will contain those
standard clauses thank you chairman
thank you
councillor
[Music]
thank you chairman i just wanted to
comment on
councilman mrs mason's uh points here uh
barley magna parish council already
release
lisa property from rochefort district
council which is their wildlife park
which is a 999 year lease
i have every intention of being there
when it needs to be renewed
this
okay
sorry chairman if i may assist
um remember there are two
recommendations set out in paragraph 7.1
on page 6.3 the report
if you are happy to
uh vote for the recommendations on block
i'll the chairman will assume your
agreement unless you raise your hand
so you're happy for the recommendations
to be taken on block
yes
yes
yes council
yeah so that's that's clear now okay so
we're voting for those together those in
favor please raise your hands
unanimous and carried thank you
agenda item seven
assets transfer said johns fisher's open
space
councillor sparring
would you like to introduce that
[Music]
thank you chairman
well i think i've explained the logic
behind the move um already in item
number six
um as members have pointed out there's
one or two little glitches that we need
to sort out which we will do and i think
i've made that point clear i foresee no
reason members why this wouldn't go
ahead everybody wants this to go ahead
and i therefore suggest that the
recommendations
on page 7.3 be adopted by the council
thank you chairman thank you councillor
do you have a seconder for that
council america
thank you madam chairman
um i'm i'm delighted to have the
opportunity to second this proposal
uh although i'm not a member
of rayleigh town council
i've lived in raleigh for some 40 years
uh
at all times within walking distance
of king george v playing field and have
therefore had an opportunity to see and
witness
how well raley town council manages that
field
and i am therefore entirely confident
that they will
manage uh
st john fisher playing field is exactly
the same uh to exactly the same standard
i'm therefore more than happy to second
that proposal thank you madam chair
councillor merrick
council and mrs mason would you like to
speak
i think council sparings
is well aware of what i'm going to say
my major concern again of this is the
maintenance schedule especially in view
of the fact that there is a building on
the grounds so i do want to see that
robustly tackled in the final report but
other than that if raleigh town council
wish this
and i'm sure they're capable of
maintaining it to a high standard i
think the reports to be welcomed
thank you
thank you councillor mason
members there are two recommendations
set out in paragraph seven one on page
7.3 of the report to grant a long lease
of amenity land at st john fisher open
space to raleigh town council
for a term of 125 years at peppercorn
rent
and to agree the heads of terms has set
out in appendix 2
that the authority be delegated to the
assistant director place and environment
in consultation with the portfolio
holder for environment and place to
finalize the lease agreement
members are you happy to vote for these
on block
please
can those in favor please raise their
hand
thank you members that is carried and
it's unanimous
agenda item 8
returning officers fees
councillor deputy leader will introduce
the report sorry chairman i'll be oh
sorry
okay
i'm not a counselor
thank you chairman chairman this report
has been bought before the council
because because it is necessary to
increase some of the fees payable to the
staff on polling stations to meet the
requirement
of the national wage increase from april
2022 the current fee structure in place
was agreed by this council in february
2019.
the proposed fees
is under table c on page 8.4
and the proposed fees will preserve the
council's ability to attract staff to
work on the day of election thank you
chairman
thank you mr
councillor
thank you chairman
so
it is proposed then that the council
resolves the three recommendations
number one
that it be agreed to retain the fees
paid
to the returning officer
at their current level and as identified
in appendix one table a
two that it be agreed to retain the fees
for clerical allowance at their current
level and has identified at appendix one
table b
three that the increased election fees
be agreed are set out in appendix one
table c for the financial year 2022 2023
unfortunately chairman the services of
the returning officer will be required
sooner than we had anticipated as an
unnecessary by-election has been called
costing us as taxpayers unnecessary
expense
nine polling stations to man the
staffing of the count not to mention all
the hard work and preparation by the
election team
these elections were not called by the
conservative party thank you chairman
councillor do you have a second uh
councillorton
thank you madam chairman i'm pleased to
uh second the recommendations set out
members are you happy to vote for the
three recommendations on block i will
assume
your agreement unless you raise your
hand
that's agreed
those in favor please raise your hands
thank you members
those against
and are there any abstentions
thank you
members that is carried
29
and one abstention
there were none against thank you
agenda item 9
pay policy for the statement of
2022-2023
jonathan stevenson chief executive will
introduce the report
thank you madam chairman
members the report in front of you um
sets out the updated pay policy
statement annual um paypal statement for
2022-23
as members are aware it's just actually
due to the requirement of the council
under the 2011 localism act to publish
the statement
report highlights the requirements on
the council and the recommendation at
7.1 recommends adopting the policy i'm
happy to take any questions if required
thank you madam chairman
thank you
do we have a proposal absolutely
do you wish to speak
counsel mrs mason
thank you for remembering on my misses
i've just got one question that i'd like
to
[Music]
ask
on the leadership team enumeration the
chief executive's role is joint but the
split between us and brentwood isn't
clarified is that an omission or is it
something that can be um
given to us the split between us and
brentwood
okay thank you madam chairman um with
regard to the split at the previous
council meeting it was agreed at 50 50
this book for the renumeration of my
role
thank you
councilman
do you wish to speak
thank you chairman um
just a question
for the chief executive
item 66 6.1
the application of the pps should
should
ensure fairness and equality in dealing
with issues of pay
i
i would hope we've done more than
think it should
deal with issues
can you confirm
that
women are paid the same as men people
with disabilities the same
paid the same as those without
that people
of a main background for instance are
paid the same as those with a white
background there's
i i'm very uncomfortable with the
statement at 6.1 it just seems like
we've glossed over it not really paid
much attention i'd like some assurances
that we have paid attention to it and
that we are walking working towards
a fairer pay structure
um or if the of pay structure is there
now and everyone is paid equally that's
fine i'd like the assurances of that as
well thank you thank you councillor
are there any other questions before we
move over to the answer
no okay
okay
thank you madam chairman um with regards
to your question obviously um the
council will make best endeavors to
ensure those fair and equitable across
the board with any pay to any member of
staff obviously i can understand the
word should
that our best endeavors is to make sure
that we will pay everybody fairly across
the board so um
we're ready with any position so
everybody will be paid equally
to the roll down the take so
with any type of just that we know
with regard to discrepancies around or
um
we'll forget sorry you've um lost my
words there
discrimination sorry rather than
discriminating discrimination really so
madam chairman thank you very much
indeed taking council hoy's point um i
think it's about words that are used and
i do accept that the word should adds an
element of doubt i would be more
comfortable with the word will
thank you madam chairman thank you
councillor
that is noted um we will now move to the
vote if there are no other
people wishing to speak
mrs mason
those in favor of that amendment
sorry chairman if i may
chairman um
councilwood we the the uh changing of
the word from should to will will be
noted in the minutes it's not actually a
recommendation for council to vote on
okay so moving on to the vote
sorry thank you
that we are voting
on the report which will include the
word will instead of should
can i just have confirmation that is the
case that has been noted thank you
council high
so we will now take the vote those that
are in favor please raise your hand
thank you members that's unanimous
please
sorry
do not have other further conversations
while you're trying to debate something
because it's very off-putting thank you
thank you councillor shaw
i will now turn to the item 10 on the
agenda
attendance at the royal garden party
2022
councillor deputy leader we'll introduce
the report thank you
thank you chairman
members an invitation has been received
to attend the royal garden party at
buckingham palace in may 2022
the number of places has been reduced by
50 this year due to a backlog caused by
the pandemic
as a result the council has been
allocated two places for one member plus
a guest
the council has for some years now
nominated members to attend based on
their total length of service as a
councillor
in addition the palace stipulates that
anyone nominated to attend cannot
previously have attended the royal
garden party in any capacity
on that basis members the council are
nominated to attend this year is
councillor robin dre
who has served as a member of this
council for nine years
it has also been best practice
that the civic car and chauffeur be made
available to transport those nominated
to the garden party
the cost of attending the royal garden
party can be met from existing budgets
and i would therefore like to move the
recommendations set out the paragraph
7.1 of the report
i'm sure that you will all agree that
councillor dre did an exceptional job as
council chairman for two years due to
the pandemic thank you thank you
councillor
do we have a second
council of whitton
okay
are there anyone else that wishes to
speak on this
okay
so members the three recommendations set
out paragraph 7.1 page 10.2 of the
report
that councillor robin dre been nominated
to attend in response to a forthcoming
royal garden party invitation for 2022
that the civic officer submits the
nomination to attend a royal garden
party by the 18th of february deadline
and the third point that the civic car
and civic chauffeur be used to transport
attendees representing rochford district
council at a royal garden party in 2022.
are you are you happy to take that on
block members
agreed
okay those in favor please raise your
hand
that is unanimous thank you members
agenda item 11 the exclusion of the
press and public
i will now move a recommendation that
under section 100 a 4 of the local
government act 1972
the public be excluded from the meeting
for item 12 of the agenda on the grounds
that it involves the likely disclosure
of exempt information as defined in
paragraph one of part one of schedule
12a of the act do i have a seconder
thank you councillor steptoe
can those in favor please raise your
hand
that's unanimous thank you members
thank you members that therefore
concludes the member the concludes the
business for this evening i declare the
meeting closed at 20
36 thank you